[Music]
on this Monday night the high stakes
meeting between the leaders of Russia
and China
Two Old Friends catch up face to face
China basically has managed to have its
cake and eat it too where the No Limits
partnership between two authoritarian
leaders could lead
collaborating to calm Financial fears
what's being done to boost confidence in
Banks and why it's not 2008 all over
again
time is running out humanity is on thin
ice and that ice is melting fast a final
warning and a glimmer of hope from U.N
climate scientists
and Pro Hockey powering forward as a kid
I knew I was queer but I was too afraid
to say anything the League's long
journey to inclusion
global national with Donna freezing good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin in Moscow and that closely watched
meeting between two authoritarian
leaders
Chinese president Xi Jinping is making
his first visit to Russia since the
full-scale war in Ukraine began he once
called the Russian President Vladimir
Putin his best friend and the two have
much in common both embrace the idea of
a multi-polar world where the U.S is no
longer dominant and both dismissed
democracy effectively appointing
themselves presidents for Life they're
expected to sign an agreement deepening
their partnership in our top story
tonight Crystal gemancing looks at what
that might mean
Russia was the first country Xi Jinping
visited after coming to power XI is now
back meeting with the man he calls his
dear friend the visit comes as she is
rotting a diplomatic High China helped
amend a long-standing rift between Saudi
Arabia and Iran but Russia is a
different story in the eyes of the West
Vladimir Putin is an international
criminal but G's visit proves he's not a
pariah to all both countries uphold an
independent foreign policy and see our
relationship as a very high priority in
our diplomacy words penned by XI and
published in Russian State media so far
China basically has managed to have its
cake and eat it too they're buying cheap
Russian food and oil they're maintaining
their trade with most of the rest of us
Russia is now the largest provider of
oil to China and China is the largest
partner for EU Imports
China has not condemned Russia for its
war on Ukraine it has floated a peace
plan and Putin says they'll discuss it
but it's the question of China supplying
lethal weapons to Russia that's of
critical interest to observers
Putin lavished Praise on ji saying we're
jealous of China's colossal leap in
development on Sunday the American
National Security Council spokesman
called Russia and China disrupters two
countries that are chafing against this
International rules-based order foreign
policy expert Michael Hanlon however is
not ready to write off the meeting just
yet if president XI is more inclined to
reinforce his commitment to the
territorial sovereignty of all countries
the non-use of nuclear weapons that
could be taken as gentle rebukes against
Russia there are calls for XI to speak
with Vladimir zielinski so that he can
get the Ukrainian perspective on the
topic of China possibly providing
weapons to Russia ji says that's an
example of the West Fanning the Flames
of War Donna all right crystal gemancing
in London thanks there is news tonight
about another uncertainty on the horizon
how the world grapples with climate
change we're already living with the
impact of extreme weather floods heat
waves and ferocious storms well today
climate scientists delivered a final
warning saying we must massively
fast-track efforts to reduce greenhouse
gas emissions
the reality is we at all levels
governments communities individuals have
made climate change somebody else's
problem we have to stop that we have to
act now Eric Sorensen lays out the
science in this final report and where
it offers some hope
it is essentially a final warning from
the U.N a potentially catastrophic
threshold for global warming will be
crossed in the next decade the signs are
everywhere greenhouse gases are
increasing air and ocean temperatures
climbing Glaciers are melting and sea
levels Rising there will be more
flooding and more droughts humanity is
on thin ice and that high sees melting
fast in short our world needs climate
action on all fronts everything
everywhere all at once in the 1970s
global temperatures annually were a
blend slightly above and slightly below
average the blue was cooler than average
fast forward to the last decade hardly
any blue at all temperatures almost
everywhere have been above the historic
average especially in the Arctic the
rate of rising temperatures these last
50 years is the highest in the last 2000
years temperatures are now 1.1 degrees
Celsius higher than pre-industrial
levels and the goal of no more than a
1.5 degree rise will be reached by the
early 2030s if not sooner the rest of
this decade is key the rest of this
decade is whether we can apply the
brakes and stop the warming at that
level the U.N report calls on the most
polluting Nations to speed up the
changes needed shut down coal production
curb other fossil fuel use and shift
more quickly to low carbon Energy Canada
is at the center of the debate a major
producer of fossil fuels and a steward
of one of the longest stretches of the
environmentally sensitive Arctic the
Canadian government has committed to
achieving net zero emissions by 2050 but
the U.N has moved that timetable forward
to as close as possible to 2040 for
Canada that's a challenge it's one thing
to to Simply say well you know we want
to reach this goal but we have to give
ourselves to mean the means to get there
and we we do that now in Canada for
2050. we will obviously need to to take
a second long hard look at what the ipcs
is proposing for 2040. critics say this
country must do more Canada needs to
finally address the elephant in the
climate policy room which is the
continued expansion of oil and gas
production in spite of the dire Outlook
the U.N report says it's not too late to
limit the harm from climate change but
we must act now Eric Sorensen Global
News Toronto
in a pre-budget speech today Canada's
Finance Minister Christian Freeland
promised targeted inflation relief is
coming for Canadians she also did her
best to quell fears about Global
Financial turmoil saying Canada's banks
are on Solid Ground
our financial institutions have the
capital they need
to weather periods of turbulence
a Hallmark of our Canadian Banks is
prudent risk management
and this is also a core principle for
those of us who regulate the financial
system
there was coordinated action over the
weekend to address fears about the
stability of the financial system the
Swiss bank UBS has cut a deal to buy its
arch rival Credit Suisse which was
faltering what depositors and investors
want to know is whether there's another
shoe to drop our senior business
correspondent Anne gabiola reports
the world central banks don't normally
have to act as First Responders these
actions are instrumental for restoring
orderly market conditions and ensuring
Financial stability but in a rare
display of global coordination not seen
since the height of the pandemic many
including Canada's are doing just that
banding and banking together to rescue
systemically important Credit Suisse in
a sale to rival UBS
from public statements to Big Financial
backing it's all about confidence and
reassurance that this won't be 2008 all
over again the Euro area banking sector
is resilient with strong capital and
liquidity positions what Regulators are
worried about right now is that crisis
of faith in the banking system becoming
a self-fulfilling prophecy if you will
where even healthy Banks might fail
signs of trouble abound though banks
around the world are in much better
shape than they were in the lead-up to
the 08 crisis but even fears of a
financial contagion alone could cause
chaos some analysts now see more
similarities between what's unfolding
and the Savings and Loan crisis in the
United States between 1986 and 1995 1300
financial institutions failed or roughly
a third of existing Savings and Loans
associations known as thrifts South of
the Border it came at a high cost to
banks that survived as well as taxpayers
back in the 1980s that was a period of
high inflation the high commodity price
of volatility and and central banks were
rapidly hiking interest rates Canada's
banks are well capitalized Diversified
and tightly regulated many experts say
even if your portfolio has taken a
short-term hit it's not necessarily time
to make drastic changes I've got my
money I'm in my portfolio I haven't
touched it I'm a long-term investor what
all of this means for Central bank's
ability to fight inflation with monetary
policy is unclear Tuesday we'll get the
latest consumer price index for Canada
and Wednesday the U.S federal reserve
will announce what it's doing with its
key interest rate the expectation is a
modest 25 basis point hike as it Treads
carefully during this time of great
uncertainty Donna okay and gaviola in
Toronto thank you now to Montreal where
the mayor wants a Crackdown on illegal
Airbnb rentals after a fire in a
Heritage building in Old Montreal one
body has been found and six people are
still missing
and I'm calling him to do his job
to forbid any type of renters who do not
respect the law rbnb Canada cannot just
say oh well we did what we had to do
it's not true and what is happening in
Montreal happens in other places in
Quebec and in Canada
police confirmed today the body of a
woman was recovered Sunday evening the
three-story Heritage building housed 15
units both long and short-term rentals
including airbnbs which are illegal in
that area of Old Montreal the mayor
wants more inspectors and greater
collaboration between Airbnb and the
province to ensure landlords comply with
the rules investigators are still
searching for six people who are
unaccounted for they're believed to be
from Quebec Ontario and the U.S police
in Quebec have confirmed a third person
has now died after the driver of a
pickup truck hit pedestrians in the
small town of amqui last week a 41 year
old man died in the hospital over the
weekend two other men aged 65 and 73
also died after they were struck on a
crowded sidewalk last Monday eight
others were injured one of them is still
in critical condition the driver a 38
year old man has been charged with two
counts of dangerous driving causing
death and police say more charges are
pending
coming up what could happen if Donald
Trump is arrested this week plus
Bittersweet birthday the family of actor
Bruce Willis on dealing with Dementia
former American president Donald Trump
says he thinks he'll be arrested
tomorrow in a criminal case involving
hush money payments to adult film star
Stormy Daniels New York prosecutors have
not confirmed anything but Trump has
succeeded in rallying his supporters who
have rushed to his defense Jackson
prosco reports from Manhattan
there is no playbook for A Moment Like
This
should Donald Trump be indicted and
arrested he will appear inside this
Lower Manhattan courthouse for
arraignment becoming the first former
president charged with a crime I would
expect that the D.A at this point pretty
much has almost all the information he
needs I think he's probably presented
the bulk if not everything he intends to
present to the grand jury and he's ready
to make a decision and move ahead
security was tight as the grand jury
worked away Monday hearing testimony
from Robert Costello a trump Ally Who
sought to discredit Trump's former
attorney Michael Cohen Cohen is the
central figure in the alleged hush money
payments made to adult film star Stormy
Daniels who claimed she had an affair
with Trump ultimately prosecutors May
charge Trump with a felony if they
believe he falsified business
information for the purposes of
concealing another crime he will have to
go through all of the normal procedures
that any defendant who is charged in
criminal court has to go through
including having a mugshot taken over
the weekend Trump speculated his arrest
could come as soon as Tuesday he called
for protests in the streets Republicans
were quick to claim political
persecution but called on supporters to
stay calm we want calmness out there
nobody
nobody for violence or harm to anything
else the Manhattan case is viewed as a
test of whether a former president is
above the law it's also the least of
Trump's legal troubles he still faces
probes into election interference in
Georgia the January 6th attack and the
mishandling of classified documents I am
convinced he's going to be indicted in
New York and in Georgia and at the
federal level for the Mar-A-Lago
documents matter but as far as what
happens next that's a big question this
is unchartered territory for us the
United States
and Jackson joins me from Manhattan
Jackson We Know Securities tight the
NYPD are on alert Are there specific
threats being made
Donna it's not so much specific threats
at this point but a broader concern
about how Trump's supporters May react
if in fact he's indicted we saw security
stepped up outside the courthouse here
today back in Washington multiple law
enforcement agencies have been meeting
throughout the day to figure out a game
plan for any possible unrest and the
district attorney here in New York has
put out a pretty forceful statement
saying that threats and intimidation
against his staff will not be tolerated
Donald Jackson all right Jackson in New
York City tonight thanks
diagnosis debate ahead what's the best
way to screen for gestational diabetes
a family of actor Bruce Willis is
celebrating his 68th birthday and being
brutally honest about dealing with his
dementia diagnosis he has frontal
temporal dementia which progresses
quickly there's no cure
his ex-wife Demi Moore tweeted this
video celebrating along with their
daughters and other family she says
she's thankful for all the love and warm
wishes Willis's current wife Emma
hemming Willis shared her thoughts on
Instagram she says people are always
commending her for being so strong but
admits she woke up crying and simply
does what she has to do to keep her
household and her life in order
I do have times of sadness
every day
grief every day
um and I'm really feeling it today
um
couple married in 2009 they have two
young daughters Heming Willis posted
this reel for his birthday even though
she says it was difficult
I know how much you love my husband and
don't cry Emma
but it means so much to me so thank you
[Music]
she and the family say they're doing
what they can to help Willis live as
full of life as possible
well gestational diabetes can lead to
serious complications during pregnancy
if it's not managed properly a study out
of BC published in the Canadian Medical
Association Journal looked at more than
550 000 pregnancies in that Province
between 2005 and 2019. during that time
rates of gestational diabetes doubled
from 7.2 percent to 14.7 percent a
change in screening methods is partly
why and as Catherine Ward explains
there's a debate underway about how best
to test for the condition
what we do know is that the rate of
gestational diabetes in BC is way higher
than the rest of the country it's an
outlier an outlier but not necessarily a
surprise for a study author Elizabeth
nethery we found that that change in
screening practice has really led to the
uh almost doubling of gestational
diabetes cases in British Columbia in
general there are two ways patients in
Canada are screened for gestational
diabetes they're commonly referred to as
the two-step approach and the one-step
method the two-step involves having a
sugary drink and then having blood work
done an hour later and if they're in the
in between zones and they go and to have
a second sugary drink that checks
actually three different blood sugars
the one-step method goes straight to the
more detailed round of testing well the
one step approach diagnoses a lot more
diabetes it doesn't actually improve
outcomes at a population level there is
debate amongst doctors and policy makers
over which tests to use diabetes Canada
reckon amends the phased approach higher
sugars lead to more complications lower
sugars lead to less confident
complications but what no one can really
agree on is where we draw that line
because there is no kind of cut point
that is very obvious gestational
diabetes is a resource-intensive
condition about a third of people will
need to start insulin which is an
injected medication we're more likely to
medicalize pregnancy which can be a
problem for for many pregnant people
researchers say more analysis needs to
be done but it may also be kind of
putting more people into this box of a
medical condition a significant medical
condition during pregnancy
in in some cases
to limited or or less benefit Catherine
Ward Global News Toronto
Pride night next the challenges the NHL
has faced promoting inclusivity
[Music]
the NHL is not really known for its
Progressive thinking and inclusiveness
and there was a reminder of that over
the weekend the goaltender for the San
Jose Sharks a guy from a small town in
Manitoba was the only player on his team
to refuse to wear a rainbow-themed
jersey on Pride night three other teams
the wild the Rangers and the Islanders
scrap plans to wear Pride uniforms all
together Mike Armstrong reports on how
hockey has changed and how in some ways
it has not the teams had a lot of fun
out there this is the part of the San
Jose Sharks Pride weekend that went off
without a hitch the team's office staff
played a game against the San Francisco
earthquakes a local lgbtq2 hockey team
the Sharks head coach was behind the
bench for the earthquakes it was a great
experience obviously uh they're very
passionate about hockey now another part
of the weekend's special programming
came before Saturday night's game the
Sharks took the warm-up skate wearing
Pride jerseys designed by a local Artist
as a kid I didn't think I was able to be
an artist and then also as a kid I knew
I was queer but I was too afraid to say
anything of the 20 sharks players set to
suit up one stayed in the locker room
the team tweeted a statement for
goaltender James Reimer the 13-year
veteran said he wouldn't participate
because wearing the Jersey would mean
endorsing quote something that is
counter to my personal convictions which
are based on the Bible loving puppies
doesn't get 100 participation right is
with the you can play project a group
that fights homophobia in sports he says
reimer's decision is disappointing but
suggests focusing instead on the Sharks
players who did wear the jersey and the
players around the league who've
supported Pride efforts one player with
a bit of rainbow tape on a stick 12
years ago would have been a story on the
front page of every sporting place
because it just wasn't done and now the
story is that all but one and I think
that's you know
we'll take it to me it's like a selfish
move primer is facing some criticism for
his decision but there are also
supporters we need more people like
James Reimer standing up for what they
believe in Major League athletes in any
sport refuse to participate in gay
rights initiatives there are some who
take advantage of the occasion good job
James there are people out there that
appreciate the position that you are
taking right now it is going to empower
Weaver admits There is almost always
some blowback but says overall there's
progress the people he feels sorry for
after Saturday's game he says the staff
and the Sharks organization who worked
on The Pride weekend and saw their
efforts overshadowed credit to San Jose
because they really really killed it
that night like Armstrong Global News
Montreal
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna Friesen it is the
Spring Equinox the first day of spring
so tonight's your Canada are these
crocuses emerging in North Vancouver and
full confession I actually took these
pictures now I know I know not everyone
in Canada has flowers blooming yet I
hope this gives you some hope
spring is here please email your
candidate to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye bye
[Music]